[Music]
why did thousands of argentines go out
in the streets to protest their new
prent when Javier mle became the first
self-described libertarian Head of State
in history he explained that to avert
economic disaster in a country facing
huge deficits and 160% in inflation rate
things would likely get worse before it
could get
[Music]
better
10 days into his term M issued a mega
decree of more than 300 executive
measures he abolished National rent
control which had caused a 75% drop in
available apartments in Buenos AIS
between 2022 and 2023 he repealed price
controls slashed subsidies and fired
more than 5,000 government
employees he allowed direct competition
with Argentina's government-owned
Airline which he plans to privatize and
he defied the country's powerful labor
[Music]
unions
the strike was organized by the general
Confederation of Labor Argentina's
largest labor unit which represents one
out of every five Argentine workers mle
issued an order ending the automatic
withholding of union dues leaving
workers free to opt out and he banned
government workers in sectors like
health and education from striking a
Court ruling temporarily suspended these
measures but in the meantime unions are
making a show of force so that relay's
agenda doesn't make it through
Congress Javier M has a seemingly
impossible job but he also has a Clear
Vision for a Freer less regulated and
less debt-ridden Argentina and he's
exceptionally skilled at communicating
that
[Music]
Vision but there are powerful political
interests determin to stop him M's main
political adversaries aren't Argentina's
workers in fact the self-described
anarcho capitalist is actually pushing
to increase welfare in the short term to
ease the pain for the working class
during this transition to a new economic
model as Argentine political Economist
Marcos Falcone told reason his
adversaries are actually wealthy
argentines who've benefited from
government laress m is is going against
Coran capitalism because he is basically
trying to tell the businessmen that have
lived off of government support you are
done this is over we need to move
forward and the people need to be able
to profit not just companies because of
regulations and
[Music]
privileges
for
M faces a Thicket of regulations and
political resistance it will not be easy
we'll have to wait and see if he picked
the right Chainsaw for the
[Music]
job